[Music]  well lumber continues to be hard to come  by for so many industries nationwide  it's an issue we've  reported on here locally among home  builders the added cost for those  companies are now being passed on to the  consumer  there's not a lot of industries that can  absorb a 70  60 70 percent increase in its demand  without having supply issues in  different parts of the country the cost  for lumber has risen two maybe three  times more  one reason is the boost in home  improvement projects that happened  during the pandemic  well now there's a construction boom  after that industry experts believe  costs will drop though in the summer but  may not go back to normal until the  middle of next year